okay so this is our honest thoughts on
Last Action Hero I make no apology you
you wanna you know what I had to take
the heat for Mortal Kombat and you left
me out there to the wolves should you
should heard what he said afterwards
about it what the people I like it or
push it like you should have got it
reads like ah fucking pussies another
like where were you when I was talking
about this and there's like Robins
mortal calm
okay okay though you like the movie
that's fine but you're not a fan of
Mortal Kombat then this is that
important comments it's the exact
opposite of me send all email to him
Karam channel I think everybody knows
like you know when you're behind the
scenes or whatever people like you know
bad talk a little bit more than usual so
just when you were saying like you know
you are unleashing yesterday I met no
that's all I said don't choose your show
I like you know yeah I got like a lot of
flack for a light not like a Mortal
Kombat you got off scot-free I was just
like um fucking pussy sitting on top is
a return gun sorry I never say that on
camera
oh I'll let you take your you're not
like my season I just I so don't get it
I do not understand it at all
oh I want my Gor yeah I think okay but
that's not what we're talking what
you're talking about last action so
anyways I'm saying I'll let you take the
lead on this no I love this cuz you've
just totally out of time I kind of works
talking light matter who's gonna be like
oh I can't like Rob Iike does the day he
hates Last Action Hero and Mortal Kombat
II promise all pussies well friend let
me Victor I don't hate less Action Hero
uh but I don't think it's very good and
the fight thing is when this movie came
out everyone kinda had the same thought
that we have like okay so isn't the
worst but it's it's not a good movie and
it bombed and all the critics didn't
like it everyone that went to see it it
kind of like Mortal Kombat at the time
everybody's like dude I thought I was
gonna get like I know it's gonna be a
comedy but if I was going to be like how
like The Expendables or something like
that you know
that came out and it was just this very
confused film that had good ideas and
I'll argue a good heart I mean like
they're trying to make it somewhat
family-friendly even though it's pg-13
but it's just all over the map and there
is a right and wrong way to sad time
that's the biggest argument I wish
you're who wants a sad tire I fucking
care that's like saying well you know
what a disaster movie I didn't like it
it's a satire yes there's a good and bad
way to do satire and this isn't the
worst way it's tomoow bleep ly sucks
it's a cynical way right now oh I'm not
gonna defend our own show you know no do
you know like it's not like how could
you not like suburban body kicks are
kick-ass it's like I get that I got
embrace only the only the only part I
can't calm Zoey like well you just
ripped off he's like no we're trying to
be satirical if you think the Santa
sucks that's fine yeah no that's totally
fine but you're like you know you're
just ripping on we're sure I see yeah to
know whether it works or not
it's called tamale flavor is enough
that's offensive to you and we're
getting so on track again II don't think
it's a good satire last action here yeah
so much uh you know and I think the
reason is that the movie that the kid
goes in it's a fun idea it's going into
a kid going to a Schwarzenegger movie
this is like every kid's dream come true
this is awesome I mean I don't love to
see I saw the trailers and if you read
the plot that's Grace should be awesome
yeah but but here's the thing they they
go into a kid version of a
Schwarzenegger film which was not
popular yet
uh I think the kind of argue like you
didn't see a like what jingle all the
way when he actually did like a kid's
film they suck and they're not very good
so the idea Tony important the closest
we've ever gotten to Schwarzenegger in a
kid's film that works is Kindergarten
Cop and the kids stuff is kind of beside
the point
yeah like it's more fun because it
really is angry Arnold Schwarzenegger
dealing with a bunch of toddlers like I
would argue that is the better satire
the
back to here because that is action
Schwarzenegger that we were used to
seeing with kids that you would normally
see them in and that was fun and it was
more horrific violence but you know
pretty intense at some point granting
was pretty crazy ya know even the Opie's
like all these like shining up you went
by me right yeah that was a better last
action hero.the last action hero um and
so you got this one where the kid goes
in and sometimes they said all rise like
the kid will say you don't say this word
grow up no you can't cuz it's uh pg-13
movie that stuff's really clever and
when the kid is pointing out the faults
in the movie where are the normal
looking women every woman is fuckin hot
but then the comebacks are pretty good
you know just it's all day it's like
that's those are good lights and those
are good ideas but then you have when he
goes into the film uh if I was watching
this film and the kid wasn't in it just
a Schwarzenegger film this will be a
stupid bad Schwarzenegger film you know
like he calls out the dogs Hank's like
you know I can have to do anything he
snapped and they're stacked on top of
each other
that wouldn't happen in an action film
there would you know if there was a
cartoon cat in it and he had a team-up
with a cartoon cat that's fine but it
would not be in the background and oh
they're all teaming up with goofy people
and stuff that's not what happens it
actually felt the one duo the one team
would be the focal this is the problem
like I got into arguments with people
online about it cuz they're like was it
sad to hurt therefore it gets a free
pass on everything I'm like now it
doesn't work that way because each
satire even within a satire has its own
set of rules I'm like okay if you're
spoofing a Schwarzenegger movie and he
goes into into a Schwarzenegger movie
then it should be the rules of a
Schwarzenegger movie I have yet to see a
Schwarzenegger where we were teamed up
with a cartoon cat but even if that's
the case there's weird other action
movies going on in the background and
I'm like I don't get what they're doing
here you know they try to come by yeah
they're trying to combine these other
cliches but again that one half an inch
for two neighbor wouldn't ease so and
the biggest I there was one thing that
really bothered me for some reason
and he's walking around they've setup
that in this world is Sylvester step I
don't know there's a long minute
yeah in the Terminator is number that's
where we huh and then there's a weird
scene that where he's walking and
there's Robert Patrick yes the t1000
t1000 cop but I'm like what in the kids
did you see do that and I'm like what is
he doing there
this doesn't make any sense well he was
on RZ Nagar film so now he's in another
Schwarzenegger film as the character
clearly addresses the cavity as the mean
look and stuff so the t1000 vodka wait
in the houses where you know that's not
talked about to people that are so
diehard about continuity yan'er doing
this hot annuity kxr like they get media
saying s what I put apart um but yeah
that that one little scene really
bothered me because I'm like okay I
guess this is just anything goes we're
not even bothering to know what we're
sand rising we're just throwing
everything on the screen and seeing what
sticks like yeah even the kid even
though I saw I was a guy so it's kind of
the perfect day John say I think I was
about 13 and when I saw driven 12 yeah
but right about 12 13 14 when I saw
Robert Patrick uh walk by I was like you
know hahaha
and then immediately after I'm like why
was that funny why is I supposed to be
funny and it just immediately confused
me I thought maybe when I got older I
could get it more but it no it makes
even less sense and honestly that the
biggest sin in the movie for me it's
like I could forgive uh uh like jumps
and logic or whatever it's okay it's
kind of a doesn't really know it's
satirizing the biggest sin firm uses
it's boring yeah it's a dull boring
movie like I when we watched it I nearly
fell asleep and I think you know there's
some scenes that like my scoring is
junior where I actually did fall asleep
I've missed fifteen minutes of that film
because I actually fell asleep huh how'd
you say that again jr. okay I pay the
junior euro zone was your New York okay
yeah that's my advice
Oh New York but no and I think okay
there's a scene where the kid is talking
to I think they have him I think they
have like Schwarzenegger daughter or
something it was pretty much grown up
and like you know the Kindle
Schwarzenegger says like you know if you
harm one hair on her head and he goes
takes a hair off and rinse it in half
now I could actually almost see that in
an action movie like it's kind of corny
but I could see a flying LCC that
commando no no but it's the fact the
music is goofy they play a cartoon
Centerpoint and so and they make it a
cartoon and that's not what kids want to
see when they're seeing a Schwartz a
felon anyone wants to see with this
English boy - nigger film uh so if you
saw this as like a really really little
kid I guess I kind of get it but you
know it's kinda like the Space Jam
arguments like yeah I saw was a little
kid fair enough but your ladies don't
vet me this is good satire this is and
it's Space Jam though is aimed at look
like I could see little kids like diggin
it you got cartoons it's basketball it's
Michael Jordan it's not aiming for
anything really high here yeah it just
is what it is but this won't I I don't
know like how many little kids watch
Last Action Hero and don't just want a
fast-forward through some of it like I
just well that's always why I'm why I
spend slow my guess is that it's kind of
like Hercules I think it's just gotten
like this kind of cult following of
people they're just like you know hey
this movie got trashed but I really
liked it I was younger yeah fair enough
like it you know if you like it but you
know don't don't try and put it up there
with like airplane or space balls or
guys no no no no we're New York we know
it's that I mean it's better than
Salters stuff like light-years out yeah
but like it can't even touch like space
balls or some of the or we Zucker work
like it's somewhere just dead right in
the middle is that right in the middle
but between Saltzer between the
higher-ups it's like right in the middle
- I'll tell you the big difference
between a something like this and
something like space balls uh is that
there was much more discipline to space
balls there's much more discipline it's
jokes because here's the thing I think
people forget and they really lose it
like you know the the date movie a
disaster movie and stuff like that uh is
that there's a million jokes you can
throw into any scene and you have to be
discriminatory you have to find the ones
that work best and contribute the most
to the scene and to the joke you're
trying to get across and in this movie
again in the movie the kid goes into a
movie you know and it's a Schwarzenegger
movie so you have to play it like a
brilliant
tonight your movie and again a great
example is Stallone doing the
Expendables which did get goofy or as
they got along but in the first film
it's like it's a satire but it is a
Stallone movie this is the movie you
would see in the 80s if all these you
wanted to it said like there is the gods
of Saturn it's a great sanitary it's not
if you want a good center what Hot Fuzz
yeah that's my thing sounds amazing
and it's a great action movie and again
gore and it's got violence and it's
hilarious and it knows what it's doing
yeah and it plays with the convention so
much more like you know all these people
will be shot up you know when when he
goes at the end it's the big climax and
stuff like that how many people died in
that nobody nobody dies and that's
amazing that as a pure we're giving you
the violence of the gore and everything
but we're also saying fuck you nobody's
dying at all it's a great play on those
conventions uh I didn't see anything
like that in this I saw good ideas that
were not figured out yet I saw people
like they're playing the script together
and they're throwing out ideas and
rather than saying okay let's pick the
best ones let's hand this make sense why
don't just go just go it's no big bowls
great I think the other thing is like I
never felt particularly with that kid
outside of a strange early scene where
he's burglarized and like god I forgot
about cops to the radiator where I'm
like okay so like where are we fooling
our arms at the same time here so I'm
like okay maybe they're implying like no
this is real yes different is in reality
it's not fun it's scary and I'm like
okay and the kid acts it out well he
seems legitimately scared and like it it
feeds into this whole thing that he's
feels very deep our to like he's
completely dominated by this other guys
I like an action movie where he can just
kick ass or three ninjas or something or
surf ninjas like you know he just gets
completely owned and is scared to death
fine but after that point like after
going into the movie then even in the
climate's I never felt any danger for
this kid like that once and that is a
difference between other earlier films
particularly like in the 80s where they
would throw kids in danger like you felt
like I think of something like cloak and
dagger wears about the kid who finds
like
the Atari game or whatever with the spy
material on it and the villain said
chase that kid and like I I was a kid I
was terrified hmm
like and you felt that it was kind of
real and I'm not saying you have to go
all out but I don't buy that the kids in
any real danger like in the latter half
of that film it's a problem yeah here
okay and here your type of that cloak
and dagger I think of aliens I think of
all these other films I think Oh nude
yeah daily yeah aliens I think that's
hardcore whore you know even commando as
goofy as it is I mean that kid looks
legitimately fucking terrified you know
yeah movie and if they really want to
make this like hey we're going to a
Schwarzenegger film how about you know
the kid switch it up the real worlds
fine for most kids it is you know it's
you know you got your movie though I
wish I was in an action film go in an
action film the action film is really
intense and animators have it be a
satire of violence in the media but I'm
having this fight and the kids like oh
my god this shit if it happens you guys
I'm fine I've got a knife to my throat
this will be like really fucking scary
and I'm interesting I'd make it a good
satire of violence you know do something
with it do something smart with it
instead like hey notice these
conventions don't these happen a lot and
that's kind of it um you know and they
don't all have to be like value said we
like airplane we like Spaceballs you
know that they're pretty mindless but
there is they knew what they were yeah
they knew what they were and they don't
have a good idea and they went for
brunch see that's the thing
airplane is so in hot shot's and those
sucker brothers films and even the early
Mel Burke stuff are so chock full of
jokes that it doesn't feel slow like
their goal was whatever gets a laugh
stays in whatever doesn't get left you
pull it in this one like just looking
for laughs in Last Action Hero it's a
slog you just kind of sit there for
minutes on end and oh it's funny there
goes Robert Patrick and oh there's a
cartoon Kevin but it's not much so it
there's not a ton of really good action
in it like I can't think of an action
scene where I'm like that was amazing I
remember something about a truck
crashing through a mansion it's like
certainly nothing that's stuck with me
it's slow the jokes aren't that funny it
doesn't really know what
standardizing someone what what's the
point well here's the thing - and I I
never got this as a kid I don't get it
now the bay if I'm remembering this
right I had maybe I'm not but the bad
guy from the film goes into the real
world he shoots someone a says you know
oh I just shot someone I just got a go
away yeah bomb and stuff like that he
realizes he can get away with much more
in the real world they can in a movie
what the fuck are you talking about
yeah since he does another thing it
doesn't know what its satirizing in the
rain room no idea what I was trying to
get could you shoot someone in it it's a
bad neighborhood I get it
bud sat only in a movie and it's pre
it's like pre 9/11 like I get that but
still like I was alive in 1993 you
couldn't do that yeah I just watched
that and I just like and again I sir
laugh but there's a kid I'm like what
the hell are they you don't really say
my satire of things you know I it's such
a weird turn around and I think that is
it I think it's like I understand making
the will were much more gritty and
mean-spirited but people can forget that
action films back in the 80s and 90s
Aaron yeah so I think the idea of going
in I really think it was predicting the
Kindergarten Cop sort of universe and a
pg-13 ization of everything maybe I
don't know but this ahead of its time
maybe maybe now we're just like the
others bring out a mob this was made
today this would be beings like
demolition man like it actually is much
better now um but back then it really
didn't make sense I would still argue
even if you make that argument the
demolition man are you mad at like no no
nowadays it makes a lot more sense I
still think the satire itself just it
still isn't focused on what most
Schwarzenegger movies are you know cuz
that is it Schwarzenegger the kid
constantly points out all the
Schwarzenegger tropes and that's what
your satirizing even if you're doing cop
movies and stuff like they have gone
with a lesser action hero it may have
worked better like your your action your
shot love it and you're one said that
years ago yeah then it's not quite the
Ober violence this is more sort of
martial-arts kind of like even their
films are pretty dark like but I don't
know yeah but even he was that in those
films what have you seen the
Commissioner yell an actual steam come
out of his eh another thing I don't get
what are they spoofing here I don't know
I mean it's again I think it's somewhere
in there I get the feeling if I started
off with an act like the first draft of
the script if I had to guess was like
sort of what we were talking about where
it's the Schwarzenegger tropes and the
kid interacting with them it just movie
tropes in general do do ya know and then
somebody was like yeah let's we have the
kid in there kids it's a kid in the
Schwarzenegger film let's make it so
that kids can see it but still kind of
make a choice in your field so make it
like a mix between Schwarzenegger film
and a cartoon and what kills me what
kills me is 1993 this is the same summer
we watched two kids nearly get
eviscerated multiple times by dinosaurs
that fucking t-rex scene like I want a
terrifying mass 14 year old in the
cinema ready to just shit a brick when
they had t-rex like burst through the
glass ceiling on the Ford Bronco or
whatever and the Raptor scenes and all
of these things that the kid gets
electrocuted on the fence I'm like think
about that for a second the you know
Steven Spielberg probably guy gave us
something that was insane Pittsburgh I
mean looking back now yeah I think
because we always serve gift Spielberg
you know uh you know Nazi but knows
little throw killer stuff but yeah you
are I think alike Temple of Doom and I
think of Jurassic Park is decided yeah
he will he will torture a fucking man's
maybe they should have handed it to
Spielberg um though that wouldn't have
been what I said at the time I mean the
director was John McTiernan and I am I
have nothing to tell the tim is a great
director um they're not all good no but
my other one
yeah but the ones that are good or
really good die hard I still made I
heard threes the best of the sequels
yeah I don't have a sequel husband yeah
Hunt for Red October
like that's one is ik I you know so I
can't I'm not even sure I can blame John
McTiernan as if he did a bad job I think
the script just suck yeah that's how do
you in your life you're a great action
director John McTiernan coming off of
die hard and things like that and you're
like now blow steam out of this guy's
ears like he must have just been sitting
there going all right yeah I try to
think is there any other movie he's done
where he's done this kind of humor and I
don't think there is even his really bad
films you know are like he's never done
yes steam is coming out there's a
cartoon kid he's never done this kind of
humor so if you're probably yeah you're
probably right that is most likely like
studio interference would be my guess um
and it's not a good screenplay like I
have no idea but again with uh it is
kind of same arguing with Mortal Kombat
and so what people are like you know oh
but it's a kid as a Schwarzenegger movie
it no you do not know Schwarzenegger
movies then you do not know the
traditional quit all employee pussy yeah
it's really true it's that you know if
you like it because you want to see
Schwarzenegger in a cartoon - fair
enough
and you're Vicki wants you something
better than Batman of Robin oh but but
that is what is it's not a kid in a
Schwarzenegger movie it's not a satire
of Schwarzenegger movies it's this very
confused mess that is not god-awful as
much as we're liking all right about it
they're doing it I want me to make
something clear because the totem pole
like there's like a totem pole we have
of things we've had to watch for the NC
which is the bar is set so low yeah Oh
Oh low uh that you know when we say oh
this isn't a great movie I think people
get I think people get confused and
they're like oh my god how can you hate
hate that film I I don't hate hate last
action hero of all the films we've
reviewed it's gotta be in the top 20
I mean we've done things like Jurassic
Park we've done things like Hotel once
are not that bad yeah of ones that are
like not that bad
like I argue overall for the problems it
has Jurassic park's a pretty good film
hook I think overall it's a pretty good
film like so it's in the top 20 of like
okay this is an eighth like this at
least is like an a-list confidently
enough done film that it's like this is
an embarrassingly bad but um so it's
it's nothing nowhere near the worst
thing we've ever viewed it's one of the
best things we've reviewed like out of
what do we are now episode three Oh what
number oh I don't I I don't count I'm
sure somebody will like half a number if
I look at all the films we reviewed like
I would probably throw it in the top two
I would probably be down near 20 yeah
like um but no I think it's I think the
reason we do get so passionate about is
because I think people you know humor is
subjective I mean ever really any of
this is subjective but I think this idea
that you know well no no you have to
defend it this should be up there with
like the greats and tires it's I mean I
think there has to be this idea of
really look at what the great set tires
are doing and what and what they're not
doing what they had to say no to what
they said okay this is a funny idea but
it doesn't belong here
uh and you compare the two and you see I
think you can see just how much more the
people in the other great San tires like
Young Frankenstein and so forth are
really trying much harder and they're
much smarter and they should be
appreciated even more for it I think
that's sort of where I say no we really
should look at these people that are
doing so much more than last action hero
is doing it if you like it fine but
there is so much more going on in these
other classic really well done
sanitizers that still hold up today I
don't like the seltzer stuff is an F the
suckers the early sucker stuff in the
early Mel Brooks stuff that's an A this
would be a see ya
you know the sound ropes work some jokes
I legitimately laughed at and I thought
we're clever yeah um but but some you
know which is better than seltzer where
I get zero
but you know it's still some and I'll
even argue that some of the ideas that
they going for are not bad ideas but do
they come through do they work I don't
think they do it's heart was in the
right place it just it's the execution
yeah uh which
I think need more executions Oh shorts
and Egger were really violent awful
people yeah we are but that was the 90
that was the early 90s it was my that
would be 80s and the early night before
things got really really PC which some
good things have come out of about
others of my times before the happy
peppy lighter tides before the pg-13
ruled the world um so but no and
definitely some good things have come
out being much more politically correct
I'm not super anti PC but it is like oh
man some of the stuff was so good you
know just just another I'm not for
sanitizing violence I'm just I think
sanitizing violence is way worse nothing
it just gives you this like oh whoa it's
okay you just shoot a guy haha he goes
on this bed and I'm like no like that
ain't right like if you're gonna shoot
somebody then really freaking shoot
somebody
hmm ya know as this or D take that one
out of counter if we were right for
politicians we be a blocker thank you
should really should sit if you're gonna
shoot somebody really shoot somebody Rob
Walker he's that the right choice for
people who don't want to get shot nope I
mean this is for the people that argue
and Expendables there's like CG blood
and stuff like that I mean and I get
that argument that this is where we're
coming from we're coming from Robocop
we're coming from Total Recall we're
coming from the Terminator films we were
me grumpy old man no but that's but what
if you're trying to understand like how
can someone not like this at tire this
is where we're coming from and that's
what we're eggs that's what most kids
were expecting when they saw this way
and that's what most kids were expecting
what they saw Mortal Kombat as well uh
yeah that kissa was so the beginning of
the pg-13 wasn't it cuz everything
started to turn pg-13 when I think of
the 90s I think two things extreme and
pg-13 yeah and two things that's
strangely enough don't go together our
extreme man
pg-13 uh so yeah honestly it I would not
say I can really barely ate this film
maybe as much as we know I I'm really
I'm in last action here when it came out
and I saw it I was completely
indifferent to it when I saw it again I
was still completely indifferent yeah I
am completely endeavor dude gets it it's
a C film if you like it whatever take it
I can't even invest enough time to
really anything even in the review I say
it doesn't work but it's not the worst
it's not awful it just for whatever
reason people take out the knot and just
hear the awful try getting through Cat
in the Hat
yeah that film I actively hate yes that
is like a last action here is a
masterpiece yeah compared to look at
that hat there you go there's a film
cool masterpiece coming in again oh so
yeah so no I think we were more reacting
to how people like are so strongly you
know you can't think that of course you
can knock it off you know you can think
whatever you want into like as much as I
said I apply city shouldn't stuff like
that it's a joke it's having fun its
humor if you really really like it like
it it doesn't matter but we're trying to
show where we're coming from and you as
well can show we're I'm gonna change
your mind I'm gonna say I like Mortal
Kombat and Last Action Hero so you can
sit all night you're just trying to want
one on me you're trying to get all hate
mail to me so I see ours uh so yeah
that's about it we will see it the next
one later